i've left california i'm in tennessee
now i've
taken a look at some videos back in
california people are not happy with
this you got conservatives who are not
happy even some liberals are realizing
this is not a good idea
there's a video that went viral of a guy
jumping up at it looks like a costco or
a home depot or something like that
standing on a table i guess walmart
maybe who knows
screaming through a bullhorn about how
terrible gavin newsom is take a listen
you know why we're under this lockdown
right now because all the information is
coming out about cobin
and they know it's a bars hey guys you
must
not do this i just keep going guys if
you continue
this is the life that you will have i
just keep going guys
don't tell me i have the right you know
what governor newsome doesn't have the
right
to shut us down for me you'll wear a
mask
that's right all right people you know
that's right
we're going to have to stand up for
ourselves because this governor
is going to keep us locked down until we
do something about it
and i want to know are you going to let
this happen
i like this guy this is my kind of guy
and the right has a decision to make
right now as
we see mitch mcconnell saying joe
biden's the president-elect
it's all basically everybody who has
anything to do with this
has given up at this point they say okay
it's going to be joe biden
i think there are a lot of republicans
who are relieved about that i think
there are a lot of establishmentarian
republicans who
sometimes they talk good game about oh
you know yeah abortion's bad give me
your money
yeah no abortion it's bad and uh yeah we
and we should stop immigration too give
me your money donate donate vote for me
vote for me
then they don't do anything about it and
they don't actually want to upset that
establishment at all
they are to use a phrase i've mentioned
on the show a number of times court
jester conservatives their their
job is to sort of put on a little show
and legitimize
the kingdom of liberalism that
establishment we have a decision to make
we all want perfect candidates we want
them to talk like reagan and fight like
trump and look like i don't know
arnold schwarzenegger we want perfect
supporters we want all this
ask yourself this question that guy
yelling on top of that table with the
bullhorn
are you on that guy's side i am i'm on
that guy's side
maybe that guy has some fringe opinions
about some things i don't know i don't
know the guy
maybe that guy doesn't go to cocktail
parties very nicely maybe he doesn't
have like a really nice fitted suit
and a really beautiful silk tie that'll
look real
i'm on that guy's side if you said
michael you can right now be friends
with pete butterjet who's look he's so
smart
he's so polished he's kind of a moderate
to you look just go you can
you can be on that guy's side or you can
be on the side of that screaming guy at
the costco
i'll take the screaming guy at the
costco that's my guy
republicans need to make this decision
are we are we going to defend i see the
argument they say look we're
conservative
and let's just conserve this liberal
establishment okay
i'm not interested in that i don't want
to do that at all i want to conserve
something a little
deeper and more important than that
and there's there's going to be a civil
war within the republican party
are we the party of guys wearing nice
suits
and billionaires and the party of yeah
maybe you keep the borders open that's
fine what
you know you got to ship some jobs
overseas it's fine gdp is going to go up
but we're going to be oh forget about
come on the cultural issues and abortion
it's not
we'll talk about it but it's we're not
going to do anything are we going to be
that party
or are we going to be the party of the
guy screaming on top of the table at
costco
i want to be the party of that guy
you